all right teddy bridgewater rejuvenates
his career last year moving up to number
29 on the chris sims quarterback
countdown list by virtue of going five
and oh so players due for a rejuvenation
in 2020 is the topic of today's draft
chris has a two-part trivia question for
me i guess i have to get both parts
right in order to get the first pick is
that what you're saying is that what
you're saying i guess i don't i don't
know i didn't make these rules you're
right what are we going to do if you get
one right and one wrong i don't know
we'll figure it out ty goes to me i
guess is what i would say okay so
louisville is the theme because of teddy
bridgewater all right but name the
louisville quarterback in the hall of
fame that's the first part let's go
there
johnny united
okay that was easy that was almost as
easy as what color is blue okay no it
wasn't easy it wasn't easy you wouldn't
have known it
of course i would have all right and
then who was the last qb drafted
before
me
in 2003.
can you remember he's from louisville
thank you there you go
all right way to go good to go yep
all right you got the perfect picture
for you better than you know those guys
i gotta go with cam newton it's gotta be
cam newton i mean we saw two games from
him last year when he had no business
playing with the injured foot that he
suffered in the preseason we still
haven't seen how this new throwing
motion that he debuted last year that
has kind of gotten forgotten in this
haze of what's up with his foot he's
unemployed he's waiting
um and and it would be a rejuvenation of
his career if he comes back and if he
plays and i think if he does and if he's
healthy we will see a cam newton that
will make plenty of coaches and general
managers and owners say what the hell
were we thinking remember there was a
point last year once it became obvious
lamar jackson was a great player there
was a report from jake laser the general
managers were scouring over draft notes
to see who in the building saw something
special in lamar jackson and who didn't
there's gonna be a lot of people
answering some tough questions if cam
newton comes back and plays the way i
think he's gonna play and the questions
are going to be why in the hell did we
not sign this guy when we could chris so
uh and i know the under and look
you can't do a physical it's a leap of
faith you got to have a play yeah you
don't want to get burned but i think at
the end of the day we're going to see
newton play for somebody and i think
he's going to play well and uh
i i suspect he's motivated
dramatically to do that
well i would think so and i mean you're
right when picking them for a player
that's due for a career region of
rejuvenation excuse me but yeah i think
uh the big thing is just where does that
happen and i i still don't know and and
you're right though i think that if he
does get a chance to get on the field
watch out he's going to explode because
he's he's got to be pissed off as a
competitor right now that he doesn't
have a seat at the table the guy that
was the mvp of football just four years
ago kind of insane um all right good
pick by you let's just say this let me
say this yeah it's got to be an injury
at this point unless things completely
go sideways for the cowboys and they say
enough with dak prescott and they
rescind the franchise tender which
they've already said they're not going
to do
right but unless something happens they
don't get a deal done by july 15 they
get exasperated and they say screw it
we're going to go get cam newton it's
got to be an injury but uh yeah go ahead
right no i agree and all right well why
we're talking about injury
i'm gonna go with todd gurley i think
he's a player due for career
rejuvenation i have a hard time saying
rejuvenation but i'm going to continue
to practice it here but either way
gurley i mean
do i expect him to be the best running
back in football no do i expect him to
be motivated and better and healthier
than where he was last year and then do
i think the atlanta falcons will use him
more than the los angeles rams because
they're a little bit of a team that's
desperate too as far as you know the
head coach and everything like that but
i think todd gurley is going to be
highly motivated by the fact that the
rams released them it came out of
nowhere we're all questioning the status
status of his knee and how good he is
the rams still haven't paid him his damn
money they owe him and all that that's
like a head scratcher to me i don't
understand that but you know i think
it's a great fit for todd gurley in
atlanta too because it's an offense that
is not going to need him to carry
the you know carry the load on a
play-by-play basis matt ryan's still a
phenomenal player they got good
receivers and they got a good tight end
who they traded for and hayden hurst so
uh i think gurley's got a better support
system around him and an offensive line
that's honestly better than the rams too
so i think he's going to show some
people this year
as you as you practice the
term rejuvenation keep in mind todd
gurley once leading the nfl in rushing
so uh he did lead it you're right
[Laughter]
all right i gotta go matthew stafford i
thought that's where you would go
matthew stafford after what we saw last
year with the broken bones in his back
that derailed his season all the talk
about is he done in detroit there was
chatter that they were trying to trade
him earlier this year ultimately nothing
came of that but there is a sense that
that this could be it for matthew
stafford selling the house in the
detroit area now his wife kelly had an
explanation for that
yeah we saw a quarterback sell his house
locally in boston last year and what did
that lead to so there's a lot of
questions about the future of matthew
stafford who's only 32. that's spring
chicken as far as quarterbacks in
today's nfl are concerned he's got a lot
more time to still play in the nfl and
he has compiled a lot of yardage a lot
of touchdowns just not a lot of
victories not a lot of playoff
appearances but uh he's due the lions
are due stafford is due so he's my next
pick
yeah i i'm not gonna lie i actually
didn't you know it's not a bad pick by
you i think there's better ones out
there that's for sure all right then
pick one
i am i just i want i want to crap on one
of yours for once you always like to do
it to me let me do it let me enjoy it
i think you you have no opportunity to
crap on matthew stafford because he
wasn't even on your radar screen i know
the way that you articulate the words i
know by your demeanor you're like man i
should have thought of matthew stafford
i if you listen to me i already said i
didn't have them on my list okay started
listening to me and stopped texting
okay
all right so here is somebody that is in
desperate need of career rejuvenation
like this is a
year like a career-defining year le'veon
bell new york jets
i mean this is it le'veon bell if he
doesn't have a good year this year
nobody's going to pay him big money in
2021 i mean he might have a hard time
finding a spot as being a
starting running back but hey when you
don't play for a year in pittsburgh and
then you come back and with the new york
jets and have a very underwhelming year
and the offense isn't good and you know
just the statistics don't look good
either to go along with the play and all
of that uh this is a huge year for
le'veon bell it is i mean come on we've
heard the rumors that the jets dangle
them out there as far as trade bait last
offseason le'veon bell acknowledged that
himself but yeah i mean one the jets got
to help levy on belmore there's no doubt
about that
uh and two hey le'veon bell he's gonna
have to make some plays this year and
he's gonna have to let let it be known
that he's got a definitive role on this
offense but this is a huge year for
le'veon bell in his career
well and i agree with you now i
addressed something in a pft mailbag on
sunday about the way the jets use
le'veon bell and we don't have time to
get into all the details but here's the
bottom line in pittsburgh they had the
offense the running back is the cherry
on top of an offense that you already
have the jets didn't have the offense
they were putting a cherry on top of a
pile of something other than ice cream
in new york that's one of the reasons
why it didn't work you gotta have the
offensive line you gotta have the
quarterback get out of the receivers all
right next one for me
i was torn between jimmy graham and eric
ibran i'm gonna go with eric abram
because we already saw him kind of
rejuvenate once with indianapolis and
then it fell off last year for whatever
reason i think in pittsburgh with a
healthy ben roethlisberger we're going
to see an eric ebrun that is going to
remind us of the guy who had the big
year with the colts and remind us of the
guy who got drafted before
aaron donald and otto beckham jr chris
well
i mean it certainly was a fall off last
year as compared to what he had done the
year before in indianapolis in the
statistical year he's in a spot where
hey the quarterback he likes to stand in
the pocket and throw the ball down the
middle of the field so eric ibron should
get a lot of touches in this pittsburgh
uh offense there's no doubt honestly
when i first heard you say pittsburgh i
thought you were going to go with juju
smith schuster too because i think he's
a guy that you can probably throw in
this draft he's on my list i'm not going
to pick him because i think there's ones
that are better but uh that you know hey
we could put big ben
eric ebron and juju smith
juju smith schuster in there for career
rejuvenation i'm going to go with my
last pick to seal the deal here for the
win for the best draft of uh career
rejuvenations david johnson
david johnson this is he needs to
rejuvenate his career for his sake for
billy o'brien's sake for deshaun
watson's sake uh but you know of course
there was a lot of scrutiny trading
deandre hopkins for david johnson what
the hell has he done the last two years
yeah it wasn't a good year last year
he's been banged up a lot over the last
few years so he is going to have a
microscope on him this year in houston
and he better have a definitive role as
far as running the football and catching
the ball out of the backfield or they're
going to be scrutinized
and people are going to talk crap about
billy o'brien the gm and everything
about it and they're going to write
david johnson off so this is a huge year
for him and i think he's in an offense
and has a team around him to to really
help him succeed
whatever he does this year what a coup
for the cardinals to unload the
guaranteed salary for 2020 that they
were not getting out of to include him
in the package for deandre hopkins and
to emerge with hopkins and get rid of a
guy that they just didn't want they had
already committed to kenyan drake it's
amazing to me that uh that they were
able to avoid that i thought they were
gonna have to do one of those trades
where
you you send the contract and you have
to send a draft pick like the broadcast
to unload david johnson so good for the
cardinals and good for david johnson if
he turns it around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports